[Music]  it's a great time for the nba and i want  to say congratulations to jason collins  for being the first active player to  come out in the history of major sports  he deserves our admiration and support  but there's someone else that needs our  support right now and that would be  jaren collins jason's identical twin  brother who also played in the nba  that's right because from here on out  people are gonna be bummed to find out  that he's not the famous gay one so  jaren get used to saying things like  this  nope i'm the other one i'm sorry to  disappoint you i'll give him your phone  number for the absolute final time i am  not jason collins and finally i am proud  to be a role model and thank you for the  free meal well good luck jason and jaron  and i suggest one of you get a very  distinctive haircut